there's some Cinderella Story with a
frat dude like leaving is one sandal
and then and someone him and some other
guy had like such a great time like
betting and like chilling and then he's
like [__]
it's like a uh like a pledge story you
know like a freshman trying to get into
a frat yeah
but he forgets which one he like he was
connecting with all the guys yeah but he
forgets he gets two blacked out he
forgets which which frat it is and then
he just leaves his one sandal there the
one sandal and the brothers are like no
we gotta get this kid he's so he's so
tight he was so sick Bro he was like the
sickest dude ever dude what was his name
I forget [__] they just then they they
host a booth on campus does your foot
fit this sandal yeah man he had this
crazy zip up
it had the logo of the school on it
and then it's sick after multiple days
of hosting the booth
brothers from all from frats all over
came and tried their tried their toes
every time they tried nah
you're not it pal
and then
these fit you but the grooves of your
feet don't fit in he's clearly worn
these for years look at the way they're
indented
totally fit his the ball of his foot and
your toes and your feet just don't fit
the grooves
the way the dirt comes off of the sandal
doesn't even appropriately
cake you at the bottom of your foot
correctly yeah it's missing parts it's
yeah it's clearly is not you young guy
pulls up in a zip up it started at the
top of his neck and went below his balls
and he had the smallest shorts ever
beneath it he was just all zip up
and backwards hat and sunglasses and he
just weren't wearing one sandal or one
sandal he goes
I think I know whose that is
so you had a chill last time
that's the only way to describe it right
you had a it was a chill ass yeah
totally chill totally totally stupendous
stupendously chill time yeah yeah it was
fantastic it was um
remarkable remarkable that was one of
them actually remarkable win
um
yeah it was it was fun it was a good
time well do you encounter any uh any
drunks any any wild behaviors not really
any of the boys get crazy you're like
whoa yeah a little bit
no fights no no fights which is good but
you know it's a very like testosterone
fueled weekend you know
a lot of this right here ready
yeah yeah yeah that's
that's usually what the boys when we're
all sitting in the same room we're all
just bucking at each other [__] you
looking at me
yeah the people listening try to
Envision hoops and hops it actually
wasn't a very loud you know you think
Ballroom 500 tables of Fred dudes do you
think it's probably [__] loud in
there now it was Stone silence Dead
Silence
all you could hear was pencils down
filling out bedding sheets yeah I do
want to shout out the the win though and
The Encore because that's the first time
I've actually stayed there and
it was awesome the rooms were definitely
nicer than any other place my great
Hotel yeah great hotel and they hooked
it up like
big time which was cool
yeah how was the set how'd it go I
didn't DJ oh no Francis canceled no I'm
I'm doing it this Sunday
so I'm going back you're going back yeah
yeah
because that's what
that's what anyone wants right
Leaving Vegas is like I can't wait to
come back here in two weeks
I'm pulling up are you scared
no not really I mean
not really a little bit I'm definitely
gonna like
like when I played the show at Winston
House like getting first like getting up
there was like oh [__] it feels like a
performance but then you're like it's
[__] you're playing music that's
already good it doesn't
you have a you have a huge leg up you
know it's like a huge massive Advantage
how sick would it be to just get on
stage and do another dude's jokes
tried and true [__] man that's what I'm
saying I do have this idea of making
like some sort of house edit of Joe
Rogan
like taking a podcast clip and turning
it into a house song but playing it off
like oh [__] I I press play on the wrong
things my podcast folder
care of him and it like turns into a
house song careful man the Joe Bros
don't play
wait they'll be like oh well I thought
we were actually gonna play an episode
The Joe Bros will be there and then
they're gonna hear it and they're gonna
stop dancing and go oh this is [__]
episode 1073. yeah yeah yo let this run
this is a good one and then they're just
gonna start chatting and pontificating
sharing ideas yeah I like this creatine
because this one makes me diarrhea less
yeah especially during March Madness
weekend that would probably [__] work
yeah
yeah that's what we should do actually
we should record an episode of the
podcast and just let another podcast
play
and I live it yeah
like oh yeah we agree with that yeah
chill
uh-huh
what he said let's go
I'm saying I did I did actually play
like a game of roulette like a session
that I won I was up like 500 bucks or
something
wow that's the first time that's
happened like hit multiple numbers
you know the energy was super high
people on the table were also hitting it
was one of those one of those rounds you
know what were you betting like what was
your number
like the uh I think the minimum was 25
so like 25 on the inside or 25 on red
and black yeah um so you start with 25
obviously until you hit and then you
kind of like just press so I think
eventually I was betting like 100 or
something and like losing like I
eventually broke even but
yeah winning on roulette is exciting
because it never happens yeah
I know but like then you get the one
session that we're like it happens
multiple times you're like oh I get it
yeah dude there's this there's I it
always feels like there's one person
that plays alone that is
either so rich or like doesn't know how
money works yeah because they come in
with a stack they like Buy in with like
two thousand dollars so then they get a
[__] stack of chips and they'll lay
the whole thing on the table okay
yes and they'll hit like the whole thing
this this woman was literally like
bankrupting herself every time playing
every single number hitting a number and
there'd be like 100 on that number so
she'd win it all back and then do the
same thing and she kept like smiling at
us like like when she hit we'd be like
nice work or we'd high fiber and she'd
like be stoked and we're like do you not
understand
what's happening here you're like to
slowly you're like just slowly losing
your sack
you know because every time she'd get a
little bit less a little bit a little
bit less back
roulette is visually so funny to see
[__]
you know however many it is
39 numbers or whatever yeah and to put
some little you know little circles on
them and then you go oh
yeah yeah
you [__] of course and then did it
and then dude the like how visual
the losses when the [__] dealer takes
all the chips with his arm and goes into
that one tiny little hole and you hear
your money just evaporating yeah
roulette you hear your kids college fun
like hitting the sides of that metal
tube as it goes down really yeah it does
such a good point roulette is the
funniest table when you lose your money
because of that [__] yeah USPS mail
shoot they have yeah
dude it's cruel it's actually cruel they
need little holes on the player's side
too so when you win you can put your
chip in a little hole and it just Stacks
it underneath the table you know so you
can take the stack out and put it back
on if not for nothing they should do
that just to make you think you're gonna
get to do that's what I'm saying it
would feel good it would feel good like
you know like uh Zamboni some chips into
that little hole for yourself for once
for [__] once